so i've seen a bunch of research about
sauna i've seen a bunch of research
about cold exposure contrast therapy
which is huge here in austin going from
sauna to cold and it seems like 20 and
three three rounds is very typical
is there something that we're gaining or
something that we're losing
by doing that cycle rather than doing a
block of heat and a block of cold
separately
not that i'm aware of but you know that
we finally have some good science to put
to this and unfortunately it wasn't from
my lab this is the beautiful work of
susannah soberg who's over in
scandinavia published a paper and cell
reports medicine showing that the
threshold you're trying to hit each week
is at least you can do more but at least
11 minutes of uncomfortable but safe
cold exposure per week total so that
could be three minutes monday three
minutes wednesday so yeah so on to 11
minutes and 57 minutes per week minimum
size that's what they found
what do they find increases brown fat
thermogenesis
thereby metabolism thereby comfort being
you know in cold etc um
clearly there's a resilience effect
clearly there's a dopamine increasing
effect and clearly you can do more you
could do all that in one day or you
could spread it out throughout the week
or you could do more it kind of depends
on what you're shooting for how cold
people always say how cold how hot well
for heat is generally
between 187 degrees fahrenheit and 212
degrees
fahrenheit somewhere in that range and
for cold it's
cold enough that you really want to get
the hell out but that you can stay in
safely because i don't want anyone to
kill themselves but doing this stuff did
i see you say that um
evening time
heat exposure
increases growth hormone release by 16
times or something insane but subsequent
sessions of the same
only increase it by a very small margin
yes am i talking about my asset no
you're absolutely right so we can
we can delineate some protocols
if you want to get better more resilient
cold exposure is going to be great
anytime
post cold exposure your body is going to
heat up
think of your body heating up as waking
up so if you are concerned about not
being able to sleep
then i would suggest you do your cold
exposure earlier in the day right
heat does the opposite so i'm laying out
some parameters here heat does the
opposite you're going to heat up while
you're in the deliberate heat exposure
but afterwards there's a post-heating
dip in temperature we talked this was
all covered in an episode deal with dr
craig heller on thermogenesis gets a
little bit down in the weeds but take my
word for it if you want to get the
science you can go there to find the
science behind this
so sauna at night is great
as well now let's think about how to
combine these things so let's say you
you know you're on a it's a tuesday
you've done your weight training on
monday
and you want to do your heat and cold
you don't have time to optimize
everything perfectly you could say okay
i'm going to do my
heat and cold at 10 a.m or 8 a.m you get
in the sauna for 20 minutes or so and
then you get into the cold for three
minutes
and then you might get into the sauna
again for 10 minutes and you get in the
cold for another minute or so you end on
cold yes why because it'll wake you up
and presumably you're not you want to be
woken up for the day that also means
don't then if you're doing it in a
facility don't then go and have a warm
shower right once you've finished right
coolest shower is fine because you want
to clean off often i mean the ice bath
is cleanish but it's you know in the
depends where you're going in
laboratories you're absolutely right in
laboratories if we want to preserve
something in particular a virus we put
in the freezer if you want to kill a
virus you heat it up
just as
dirty of a sauna as you want but the
cold tub well yeah the sauna sort of its
own autoclave if it gets hot enough
right and the cold cold stuff needs to
be cleaned out now and again you get
mold growing in a in a freezer which is
kind of freaky to think about but you
really can't it's never going to grow in
a sauna never going to grow if it gets
hot enough now there is what i call the
sober principle
which is if you are using deliberate
cold exposure to increase metabolism end
on cold so finish on the cold not just
because it wakes you up more but because
then you have to heat your body up
naturally which is a thermogenic
metabolic response
so end with cold and if you really want
to push it you can do things like don't
use a towel use evaporation
spread out your limbs and don't huddle
so that you have to shiver more etc i
mean a lot of little games you can play
but let's say you want to reduce post
exercise inflammation you're not
concerned with hypertrophy gains of
muscle size gains or strength gains well
then get in the cold after your your
workout do that for one to some people
can do 10 minutes reduce inflammation
let's say you really want to hit growth
hormone which is what you asked
the biggest effects of sauna on growth
hormone and they are big effects are
when the sauna is only done once per
week
but it's done in four cycles or sets we
could say of 30 minutes each so that
means 30 minutes in the sauna at the
temperatures i described before then a
five minute break just air cooling off
or ten minute break then back into the
sauna for 30 minutes this is brutal then
again in the afternoon 30 minutes in the
sauna
then
10 minutes just air cooling off and then
back into the sauna for 30 minutes so
that's two hours at 187 to 212 degrees
one day in one day with a maximum of
what less than sort of 20 minutes
of rest in between those little sessions
than the big rest in between so you have
to be very careful right heat can kill
you you got to hydrate you need to make
sure you get enough salt like it i mean
this is this is work right um but you
get you see in these human studies up to
16-fold increases in growth hormone so
you can imagine this could exert some
very strong reparative effect if you're
training for a big event or endurance
event or maybe you're just really wiped
out from the week this is a stressor but
it's a stressor that delivers a potent
growth hormone response now if you do
sauna more often than that
you're not going to want to do two hours
a day in the sauna because presumably
you're doing other things you have a
life you have a life and in addition to
that the growth hormone effect starts to
diminish if you become too heat adapted
and that raises a more interesting
question perhaps which is why is it that
this two-hour protocol really works if
you do it once a week to increase growth
hormone it's because it's a stressor and
certain stressors increase growth
hormone
does it have to be heat no you probably
also do four really long rounds of ice
bath and i'm guessing you'd probably see
a similar effect no one's ever really
looked you'd probably see a similar
effect because it's all about the stress
stimulus now those that work on exercise
science and weight training would
probably say yeah you could also do
a
this has been shown you know at 90
minutes 10 sets of 10 multiple exercises
for 10 sets of 10 high volume german
volume training work out and get the
same growth hormone effects there's so
many studies like this
i personally like to do the sauna two or
three days a week
and
if i'm traveling off and don't get the
opportunity if i'm in austin it's great
because there are all these sauna places
but if i'm traveling abroad i don't have
the time then i might do i might take a
day i'm thinking wow i did three
podcasts i'm exhausted when i'm in new
york i like to go to a place i have no
relation to them but i think it's called
spa 88 it's a russian banya and i'll
just go for the whole day
if i've been working really really hard
they serve food there they sort of
borscht and all this other kind of like
pickled vegetables and um they must
think that you're russian you they must
you must walk through the doors and they
go hello brother sometimes i usually
just don't the best way to to appear
russian lex i hope you're listening is
just not saying anything just just to
know that's the most russian thing that
you can say is nothing exactly very
stoic
um that place is great and they have
different saunas steam sauna they have
cold dunk and sometimes i'll just spend
three four hours there there's one in
san francisco called archimedes bonya so
sometimes that's an occasional thing now
most people are trying to incorporate
this into their daily life and just like
as we said for ice bath if you don't
have access to ice or ice bath or cold
tub you do cold shower
or longer cool baths with heat i realize
not everyone has access to a sauna hot
baths do work now one thing about hot
baths and hot sauna is they will nuke
your sperm it's not new a nuke is a you
know slang
they will reduce viable sperm counts so
for males that are trying to reproduce
you know trying to create children
you want to be careful about hot baths
and hot sauna too often some people will
bring a cold pack in and put in their
groin you can't do that in a bath
but
i mean sperm are maintained outside the
body the testicles are maintained
outside the body
um you're right the scrotum has varying
elasticity in order to maintain
temperature of the sperm that's why that
that's the the various effects that have
been described are there on purpose um
so
why human evolution design this way i
don't know someone will say but
in any case
unless you're trying to you know and
again the ice pack approach is
interesting um some people do that
actually there's a kind of interesting
relationship between cold and
testosterone and thermogen and
spermatogenesis there's a little cottage
industry out there i think on amazon
people will buy these gel pack underwear
of cou i think they're called snowballs
this is
cooling the scrotum in order to try and
increase spermatogenesis okay now i'm
not aware of any data on this but people
report anika data and have shown their
blood work and stuff
that it
it actually works to increase
testosterone levels i am not aware of
any periodic studies i am not i'm not i
would not be sitting as comfortably as i
am right now
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace